while taking to the ice to help an
injured metro police officer that's what
hundreds did tonight all to raise money
for officer shane michelonis and his
family arko mana is at city national
arena with more on the fundraising event
we're told officer shea michelonis is a
huge ice hockey fan so what better way
for the community to support him than
through a charity hockey game and it all
started with a special surprise
[Music]
metro police officer shea mccollonas
takes the ice as cheers echo around city
national arena joined by his family he
does the ceremonial puck drop at friday
night's play for shea hockey game i
actually got him into the police team
and he skated with us a lot before his
injury metro detective justin roth is
officer michelonis close friend it's
still hard for him to think about last
summer when officer michelonis was shot
while responding to a protest on the las
vegas strip he's now paralyzed from the
neck down
[Applause]
detective roth says playing in the
charity event is just one way to stand
behind his friend it's been a long road
for shea we've been here to support him
go versus house every now and then we
play chess the close to 350 people in
the stands paying 20 dollars each to get
in all the money including from t-shirt
and puck sales going to officer
michelonis and his family we did a
golden night and a sober night and then
a hockey player
this 12 year old selling engraved hockey
puck says he just wanted to help i have
multiple family members that are cops
and firefighters so it meant a lot being
out here the proceeds will be given to
the micollonis family through the
injured police officers fund i'm sure
the family is just beyond grateful and
it's the least that we can do for shea
for what he sacrificed for this
community
the two teams on the ice all here for
one purpose to support shea kid's a
fighter he wouldn't be here if he wasn't
a fighter again all the money raised
will go toward officer shea's family and
toward his recovery reporting from city
national arena orca mana 8 news now